let me kind of recap what happened for
you and we'll bring this stuff up on
screen as I do last night BuzzFeed ran a
35-page intelligence report claiming
that Russia had some seriously
compromising content on Donald Trump
something to do with Russian broads and
urination it was golden shower gate
it was the trend CNN was all too happy
to go along with this they claimed
intelligence gave Trump a two-page
addendum to last Friday's report this
was by the way this was even in question
from the New York Times so it came out
from BuzzFeed okay when you first heard
about this you thought oh my gosh this
is gonna this is bad for Trump right
well I think you at this point like come
on but I think people who weren't
following the news super closely who
don't really understand fake news
meaning CNN meaning BuzzFeed versus real
News thought oh this is what's going to
seal Trump's coffin so here's the truth
the 35 page report was provided by
opposition research to Trump rivals and
Hillary Clinton's supporters and this
was prepped by a retired British
intelligence officer who was paid to
create a report hurting Donald Trump
here's the thing Donald Trump has made
some mistakes we've talked about this
the media has they're just in Scott of
proof they just keep giving him these
gifts you know the Russia thing they
maybe were able to tie tie it together
they could have perhaps run with the
story that Donald Trump is flagrantly
disregarding the Intel community Rick
Santorum at the brilliant point that
he's not that he's act he's at war with
heads of intelligence committees not
intelligence agencies themselves and you
can see that right the left was furious
with Comey it's not like it's exclusive
to the right sometimes you have people
who are in positions of authority and
you have a problem with it the left
could have run with that and said that
Donald Trump does have a problem with
people in the CIA doesn't believe the
briefings we find this irresponsible you
would have gotten more you would have
made more traction with that but you
give them the gift of something from
BuzzFeed from BuzzFeed Ben Smith about
Donald Trump pissing on Russian
prostitutes and you run it out there and
there is ZERO substantiation to the
point where Tom Brokaw one of the most
leftist reporters ever next to Dan
Rather then all who roll
for a while he was really saying and
professionally I'm surprised how moronic
you are he knew that it was false
imagine him sitting back in his in his
reclining leather chair watching CNN and
that he sees the report the 35 page
report that he knew that he debunked
behind the scenes was unable to
corroborate three months ago oh dear God
they are you want to talk about fake
news this is fake news CN n so fart they
have soiled themselves so many times now
it's going to make it too easy for
Donald Trump and people were worried
about Donald Trump maybe stepping on the
press too hard not entirely
understanding the First Amendment kind
of like Barack Obama banning Fox News
but you make it easy for the guy to shut
you down at this point it's it's it's a
worthy shutdown right Donald Trump
saying I don't like she attack your
ratings suck you overrated I would have
put a you know okay like that would be
bad and I think that all the pressure
should be allowed but when they're
saying mr. Trump did you urinate on
Russian servant girls shut up that's
that's not that's not really something
that's indefensible they gave him the
gift and then Donald Trump is a gift
that keeps on giving because he had a
press conference today and what's so
funny is you knew he was just sort of
sitting waiting bobbing and weaving and
loading up on that right hand and he had
his press conference the first one I
think since he's become the
president-elect let's see what that was
like thank you it was a disgraceful
disgraceful that the intelligence
agencies allowed any information that
turned out to be so false and fake out I
think it's a disgrace and I say that and
I say that and that's something that
Nazi Germany would have done and did do
I think it's a disgrace that information
that was false and fake and never
happened got released to the public as
far as BuzzFeed which is a failing pile
of garbage
[Music]
here's the thing there are a lot of
things I don't like about Donald Trump
sometimes but him calling the media out
that's when we rally that's when we're
yelling in the blue face politically
that's when we win that's when we win
there was more than happen in the press
conference when you let's let's get to
what really it's all fake news it's
phony stuff it didn't happen and it was
gotten by opponents of ours as you know
because you reported it and so did many
of the other people it was a to be
called reporters since it got together
sick people and they put that graph
together so sick people crap can you
believe it though I can't it think it's
better it's better sir
quiet mr. president like go ahead you
state categorically the person who like
can you give us a question you're
attacking us can you give us a question
B can you give us a question and you
have got to give you can you state can
you stake a turd you are fake dude sir
can you stake
[Music]
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if you're
not aware of it now there's no way
you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand at smug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside